très mauvais d'après truies si tu mens
ou épaisses et mes poumons par les temps
qui courent on vous demande beaucoup de
faire une rétrospective de certaines de
bowser
j'ai réalisé qu entre 1976 et 1986 vous
avez vraiment beaucoup travailler
peut-être plus tôt même passé eu du mal
à l'épaule nous appelez moi stéphane ont
leur place vous ai vue d'une annonce de
boire un champagne fusionnera zain une
loi ravinois les voisins de cette fille
si aucune idée brooke shields ou de vol
là on met la table à digne des personnes
un peu fou non oui mais il est toujours
encore l'impression j'ai pas fait grand
chose qui allait mois la chute d'âge
adagio je mets toujours raison que c'est
d'avoir fait ce que je voulais faire
alors oui j'ai même créé j'écrivais tout
le temps il ya une période avec louis
saïa on était toujours ensemble en train
dé créer ses terres on était en feu
vraiment intéressant comme les cris les
voisins appelez moi stéphane la même
année ou presque qu'on avait écrit brou
puis moi je faisais pas l'épaule mais
rappellera juste frappier un jour 9e dit
toi cloud le jour où tu vas arrêter de
faire la parité parce que j'étais un peu
avec parti rejetant tournée avait dit
cette note écrite soit peut-être réussi
à faire quelque chose vous avez dit
merci rejoint le check up paris oui ça
nourrit c'est tout ça et puis en tournée
au québec puisqu'on fait le monde soit
refaite paris bastia ne compte pas non
mais je t'invite paris j'étais quand
même un gars qui travaille énormément
beaucoup parce que j'avais une gagneuse
tab en effet reversé notre grain de marc
messier serge thériault à michel côté
louis saïa chez le ritz ce test est bel
est bien existence bien excitant était
trop beau personnage s'entrecoupent mais
j'ai un peu l'impression que tu y mets
est né pour pas est né en 1981 dans le
bye bye bye bye
en marche avec cet accord dans ce sens
il avait un rôle dans les attaques ont
exactement le choc des cultures c'est le
nom de ce sketch où c'est un personnage
qui n'a pas pas encore de barbe s'est
mis au tennis hall eurent fait est qu'à
un peu où il parle un peu comme papa et
moi je toujours pareil et il donne nous
titille pas d'un peu de maine alors
c'est quoi différentes
je bois trop nantis mais pour moi il est
plus vieux il peut incarner mais c'est
vrai que papa il ya peut-être vu jour la
mémoire c'était pour pas bernard bernard
des voisines données données dans l'est
sur toit d'un outil mais ce soft une
filiation moi c'est mon père était beau
soleil à peu près d'accord politique tel
niveau
j'ai travaillé j'ai passé du temps à
l'écriture de la vie j'ai passé six ans
de ma vie à cinq ans de ma vie
j'écris toujours à peu près de 15 pages
par jour j'en achetais 7,8
mais ce que je devais pas aux lancers
que c'était un plaisait j'étais dans un
état de trois heures de temps 3 en trois
heures et demie de temps j'écrivais vite
et beaucoup mais pour ce genre était
bien jouer au tennis ou du budget déjà
jeté caddies saut pour vous autres lots
mais je pense que him un genou à terre
une chose j'ai pas la preuve défini j'ai
toujours un besson qu'elle continue
parce que les gens m'en parlent encore
autant qu'au début - la petite vie pour
moi est encore présent beaucoup beaucoup
dans ma vie mais les gens disent
toujours terrail je la connais et y
lisons c'est ma belle-soeur rénale c'est
mon frère mon mari city mais j'avais des
projets qui ont moins bien fonctionné
que d'eau oui comment se nourrit de ses
échecs lors pour avance sincèrement se
nourrit pas ben ben c'est souvent
quelque chose qui nous fait reculer ou
qui nous ont paralysé pour un butin
c'est parce que j'ai léger comme les
mecs comme moi je suis un orgueilleux
que je le prends mal puis je prends pas
mal de critiques
je prends très mal la critique quand la
critique va trop loin puis souvent moi
moi j'ai pas eu beaucoup de facilité
avec la critique
[Musique]
mais dans la vie j'aime pas me faire
critiquer je suis quelqu'un l'a
difficilement critiquable mais je les
accepte maintenant je l'accepté vous
laissez passer toujours trois ou quatre
entre chaque projet le ça va faire trois
ans j'avais pas remarqué l'ancien
diplomate
enfin trois ans pour le team et chez
qu'est ce qui s'en vient
s'ils arrivent quelque chose ça va être
vraiment du côté du terral d'une
impression parce que le cinéma j'ai bien
aimé sur faire mon film j'ai adoré ça
puis on m'a dit ravi ravi missiles en
cinéma au québec ça prend quatre cinq
ans puis j'avais dit sujet mais sans
contredit sujet sérieux sinon n'irait
pas dans le sérieux lorsqu'ils ont fait
appeler ses doigts point que ça des gens
veulent pas que je sois si sérieux c'est
vrai mais j'ai j'ai une idée de g comme
un projet de théâtre devrait créer
protégeable probablement jégou
d'automoteurs de façon j'ai tout écrit
du terrain dans le fond nuage à face
afin de terrain ma vie est imputée au
trader
claude meunier merci mille fois c'est
agréable mr-63 vinci